now ready for Part B and I've wiped all
the salt off of my fingers and I've had
a glass of water so now I'm ready for
some business find the second derivative
of W with respect to T in terms of W use
this second derivative to determine
whether your answer in Part A is an
underestimate or an overestimate for the
amount of solid waste that the landfill
contains at time T equals 1/4 so let's
do the first things first let's find the
second derivative in terms of W and we
already have the first derivative over
here and in Part A I rewrote it just
with slightly different notation but
I'll just use this just because I need
to write down here and I can still refer
to this thing so let's just take the
derivative of both sides of this of this
differential equation with respect to T
so you take the derivative of this
left-hand side with respect to T you get
the second derivative of W the second
derivative of W with respect to T as a
function of T is equal to now you take
the derivative of this with respect to T
this is the same thing as 1 over 25 w t
minus 12 and so when you take the
derivative that constant part drops off
and you're just left with you're just
left with 1 over 25 times the derivative
of W T and we making it let me make that
clear this is the same thing as 1 over
25 W 1 over 25 W as a function of T
minus 12 125th of 300 is 12 and you take
the derivative of this you get 125th
times the first derivative of W and then
the derivative of this with respect to T
is just 0 a constant obviously does not
change with respect to T and so we get
this right over here now this is the
second derivative in terms of the first
derivative
but the question asks us write the
second derivative in terms of W but
lucky for us we know how to express this
we know how to express this as a
function of W they gave that to us in
the problem this was given this is just
me rewriting it in a different notation
so this is going to be the same thing as
1 over 25 1 over 25 times the derivative
of W and the derivative of W is this
this is the differential equation
Liberto so the derivative of
you is this over here so one over 25
times 1 over 25 w t or the function W is
a function of t minus minus 300 and so
we can say the second derivative let me
write a little smaller so don't waste
space the second derivative of W as a
function of T is equal to 1 over 625
times W as a function of T which is a
function of t minus 300 so we've done
the first part we've found out the
second derivative of W in terms of just
W now let's try to address the second
part of their question so we did the
first part now use what we just figured
out to determine whether your answer in
Part A is an underestimate or an over
estimate of the amount of solid waste
that the landfill contains at time 1/4
so in Part A we found the slope we found
the slope of the tangent line at time
equals 0 and we use that slope to
extrapolate out to three months or time
equals 1/4 1/4 of a year now if the
functions double use slope over that
fourth was exactly the same as the slope
of the tangent line or if that slope did
not change then our extrapolation would
be exactly right
if w's slope is increasing over that
time then our then our estimate would be
an underestimate of the correct thing
and if the slope is decreasing over that
time then our estimate would be an over
estimate of of the actual amount in the
landfill and to figure out whether the
slope is increasing or decreasing we
just have to look at the value of the
second derivative if the second
derivative is positive that means our
slope is increasing which means that our
extrapolation would be an understatement
let me just be clear here let me draw
this let me make it very clear so let me
just draw a random function so let's say
that's W so this is a case where w's
slope is increasing faster or a W slope
is increasing from that starting point
so our starting point this was our slope
and then W slope keeps increasing from
there and in this case our estimate is
going to be an under
estimate of where W is actually is after
a fourth of the year if doubles use
slope is exactly the same as our
function over the course of the year
over the course of the first three
months so it would look something like
that maybe a diverges later on and in
this case our approximation would be a
really good it would probably be exact
for W and if w's slope for whatever
reason goes negative after that point
and we they already tell us it's an
increasing function so that is that is
not likely but or well it could it
doesn't have to even go negative if W if
W slope decreases it could still stay
positive and the way I drew it doesn't
really draw it like this just to make it
clear so let's say that let's say we
find out that the slope looks something
like this this is this is the slope of
the tangent line at time equals 0 if W
slope increases from that point then W
might look something like that and then
of our our our answer to Part A would be
an understatement
would be an underestimate of where W
actually is after 1/4 of a year let me
draw it make it clear to you what I'm
doing so this is this is my W axis so
this is right at our initial condition
of 1400 and that this right over here is
our time axis and this is at 1/4 so in
the last video we said hey this is
sitting right at 1411 if W slope
increases from that point then this is
an underestimate if WS slope stays the
same then this is actually a very good
estimate because then we're going to be
we're going to hit that point directly
with W and if W slope decreases so you
can imagine maybe W look something like
this its slope it has that height it has
that slope of the tangent line when it
starts but then the slope decreases and
it's still an increasing function but
the slope is decreasing and in that case
we would have we would have an
overestimate and in this this is a
situation so this first situation slope
is increasing that means that means W
prime prime is positive W prime prime is
positive the slope is increasing the
second derivative is positive this means
or this would be a byproduct of or this
would
cause the second derivative to be
negative our slope is decreasing and
this would be our second derivative our
second derivative is zero if your slope
isn't changing your second or if your
slope is constant if your first
derivative is constant your second
derivative is going to be zero so let's
just see what our second derivative is
at our initial condition and then we'll
have a pretty good sense of whether we
have an over estimate or an
underestimate for Part A so let's just
figure out what our second derivative is
at time zero is going to be equal to one
over six twenty-five times w of zero
which we know minus 300 well W zero or
the amount of waste we have at time zero
they told us in the problem is 1400 1400
tons 1400 minus 1300 is 1100 and then
1100 minus 1100 divided by six 25 is a
small number it's one point something
but it is a positive number and that's
the important thing here so this thing
all of this business it is positive it
is positive so the second derivative is
positive which means the slope is
increasing at least right at our
starting point our slope is increasing
which tells us that our since our slope
is increasing from that point and
frankly the fact that it's increasing at
all and that we know that W is an
increasing function tells us that our
that our estimate in Part A is an under
estimate so this is this is the case
that we're dealing with so our estimate
in Part A is an underestimate of the
actual amount of solid waste in the
landfill at time T equals one-fourth